The Marvel Cinematic Universe only scratches
the surface when it comes to Mjolnir and Stormbreaker.
From their legendary origins to their modern-day
enchantments, here’s the truth behind Thor’s
magical weapons.
You might already know this, but the god of
thunder goes back way further than their Marvel
Comics debut in 1962, and so does his thunderous
hammer.
Mjolnir got its origin story
in the 13th-century Prose Edda, and like most
Norse mythology, it involves Loki causing
trouble.
In this case, he made a wager with a pair
of dwarves named Brokkr and Sindri you may
know them from the 2018 game God of War betting
that they couldn't craft three magical items
that were the equal of Asgard's three greatest
treasures.
To rise to the challenge, the blacksmithing
dwarves set about working their forge and,
despite Loki's interference, they crafted
a trio of treasures of their own.
The most well-known, of course, was Mjolnir,
which turned out to be a pretty good hammer.
As powerful as it was, Mjolnir wasn't Thor's
only piece of equipment in the myths.
To heft the incredibly heavy hammer, a problem
that he had to face long before Marvel Comics
came along, he had to use another pair of
magic items.
The first was the Jarngreipr, a pair of gauntlets
known as the "Iron Grippers," and the second
was the Megingjord, a belt that doubled his
already considerable strength.
"We just gotta load Tony's old Hulkbuster
armor, the prototype for Cap's new shield
and the Megin..
The megin…
Thor's magic belt."
Over the years, Marvel has added or adapted
most of the mythological stories behind the
Norse gods, so it's not surprising that both
of those items exist in the comics.
However, the Megingjord shows up rarely on
the page, and to explain why Thor doesn't
just wear it all the time to double his strength,
Marvel's version, according to Thor #363,
takes a pretty serious toll on the god of
thunder.
Marvel's version of Mjolnir first appeared
in Journey into Mystery #83, loaded up with
a few interesting spells to make for more
exciting superhero comic stories.
The first, of course, was the familiar enchantment
by Odin that meant only the "worthy" could
lift it.
"Whosoever holds this hammer, if he be worthy,
shall possess the power of Thor."
For the other, though, it seems like the Marvel
masterminds may have been taking some inspiration
from a lightning-powered hero who was a little
more recent than the Prose Edda.
In the Golden Age of Comics, young Billy Batson
discovered a wizard in a cave and said the
magic word "SHAZAM!" to transform with a thunderous
blast into Captain Marvel, the World's Mightiest
Mortal.
He even shared his power with his sidekick,
Captain Marvel Jr., whose secret identity
was Freddy Freeman, a young man whose injured
leg led him to walk with a crutch.
Captain Marvel stopped being published in
the '50s, though he would eventually come
back as DC's Shazam, renamed for various legal
reasons.
Fans might've found an interesting alternative
in 1962, though.
Marvel's version of Thor was secretly Don
Blake, a doctor whose injured leg led him
to walk with a cane.
He discovered a stout stick in a cave, and
when he smacked it against the ground,it turned
into Mjolnir and transformed him with a thunderous
blast into Thor, the World's Mightiest Immortal.
Blake was then blessed with the strength and
power of Thor.
Whether the Marvel bullpen was actually trying
to recapture the magic of Captain Marvel Adventures
by giving it some of that hot Viking flavor
is certainly up for debate.
Marvel's most enduring addition to the Mjolnir
mythos was the enchantment that granted the
power of Thor to those who were worthy of
it.
Anyone who was worthy of it.
Over the years, that's a list that has included
a surprising number of names, but the more
notable examples include Steve Rogers, who
first hefted the hammer when he was operating
as "The Captain," and later lifted it in his
more familiar identity of Captain America.
"...assemble."
Squirrel Girl also got her hands on the hammer
and used it to stop a misguided duplicate
of herself who couldn't lift the hammer from
beating up the Marvel Universe.
The most eye-catching for crossover fans,
however, came at the climax of JLA/Avengers,
when Superman charged into battle wielding
both Captain America's shield and Thor's hammer
to save the day.
Once the battle was over, however, Superman
found himself unable to lift it, leading Thor
to explain that Odin occasionally sees fit
to suspend the enchantment for special occasions.
In 1983, Walt Simonson took over as the writer
and artist of Thor with #337, and he certainly
brought in plenty of new ideas.
The first big shift?
Ditching the Thunder God's human identity
and making the new Thor a space horse.
Okay, it's slightly more complicated than
that.
While investigating something in space, Thor
encounters an alien warrior named Beta Ray
Bill.
In the fight, Thor loses his hammer, and thanks
to yet another enchantment that required him
to keep in contact with it to maintain his
godly form, it turns back into Blake's walking
stick.
A very frustrated Bill grabs the stick and
smacks it against the wall, and readers suddenly
learned that this strange new alien who definitely
seemed like a bad guy is every bit as worthy
as the guy with his name on the cover.
Bill transformed into a new, sci-fi Thor,
and was promptly whisked off to Asgard because
Odin's summoning spell was looking for "Thor,"
not his son.
Over the next few issues, Bill has to battle
to the death against Thor to determine who
would be the true god of thunder — which,
if we're being honest here, is some pretty
rough parenting from Odin the All-Father.
In the end, though, Bill ended up saving Thor's
life and proving himself to be a good and
noble soul who just happened to look like
a giant skeletal horse.
Bill swore his loyalty to Thor as his "oath-brother,"
and to reward his nobility, Odin had Eitri
the dwarf craft a new hammer to be Mjolnir's
equal: Stormbreaker.
It was every bit as strong, had the same enchantment
about worthiness, and the only big difference
came in the aesthetics.
Stormbreaker, while made of the same Uru metal
as Mjolnir, appeared golden and had one flat
hammer-head and an ax-like blade on the other
side.
Beta Ray Bill isn't the only strange transformation
that Thor underwent during Walt Simonson's
five-year run.
At one point in the comics, Thor found himself
turned into a frog thanks to — let's say
it all together now — Loki.
While he was a frog, he got caught in a Secret
of NIMH style war between New York City's
frogs and the ravenous sewer rat population
that was being controlled by a bad guy with
low aspirations called the Piper.
The whole issue was built around a struggle
for Thor to recover his hammer, and when he
did, he struck it against the ground and was
thunderously transformed into … a six-foot
six-inch frog dressed like Thor.
That's not the end of the frog's story, though.
While he was briefly amphibious, Thor spent
some time hanging out with a frog named Puddlegulp,
who it turned out was also a human transformed
into a frog, because that's the kind of thing
that happens when you're living in a universe
full of wizards.
At one point, however, Puddlegulp found a
shard of Mjolnir that was chipped off by one
of Thor's chariot-pulling goats.
Puddlegulp lifted the shard, struck it against
the ground, and became Throg, the frog of
thunder.
Unlike Thor's time as the thunder frog, Throg's
was still frog-sized, with a tiny Mjolnir
to match.
This hammer had all the abilities of the regular
version, and was thus given the extremely
on-the-nose name of "Frogjolnir."
In 2014, Thor came to the conclusion that
he was no longer worthy to wield Mjolnir,
and that lack of confidence became a self-fulfilling
prophecy.
While Thor was being glum about this turn
of events — and getting his left arm chopped
off by Malekith the Dark Elf in a pretty disastrous
attempt at hammerless crime-fighting — Jane
Foster, believing that there must always be
a thunder god to stand against evil, hefted
the hammer herself and became the Mighty Thor.
For the next three years, Jane was Thor, but
her tenure as the goddess of thunder came
to crashing end when Mjolnir itself was destroyed.
It happened during a battle with the Mangog,
a creature that had come into being in a past
era when Odin destroyed an entire planet,
and the pure hatred of its population coalesced
into a nearly unstoppable monster.
The key word there, however, is "nearly."
Jane did end up stopping the Mangog by chaining
him to Mjolnir and hurling it into the heart
of the sun.
As you may know from science, the core of
the sun is roughly 10,000 degrees Fahrenheit
and contains a constant nuclear reaction.
That turns out to be about the level of force
that you need in order to destroy a presumably
"unbreakable" magic hammer.
Mjolnir was vaporized, Jane retired from Thor-ing,
and the Odinson once again took up his heroic
exploits, using a series of substitute hammers
crafted by a dwarf named Screwbeard.
Sadly, due to a shortage of the mystical Uru
metal from which the original Mjolnir had
been crafted, none of the replacements were
as good as the genuine article.
Mjolnir may have been destroyed forever, but
this is comics.
It's only a matter of time before everyone
comes back from the dead, including hammers.
In this case, it happened during 2019's War
of the Realms, a crossover event that, shockingly,
was not Loki's fault.
Instead, it's Malekith again, leading an invasion
of Midgard, or as we call it, Earth, from
the united forces of the other realms.
At the climax of the story, Thor conjures
up the God Tempest, a storm so powerful that
it affects the sun itself, reforging Mjolnir
and sending it crashing back to Earth.
The reborn Mjolnir was pretty recognizable
as the original, with the exception of the
handle.
This incarnation had a handle made of braided,
natural-looking wood, presumably to bring
it more into line visually with the version
of Stormbreaker that moviegoing audiences
would've seen in Avengers: Infinity War and
Endgame.
It also retained the worthiness enchantment,
but Thor now saw worthiness as a struggle
that we all face to be better, declaring himself,
along with his new hammer, to be the god of
the unworthy.
While they're easily the most notable ones,
Mjolnir and Stormbreaker are far from the
only Asgardian weapons to show up on the page.
Most of the weapons that originated in mythological
sources are present in the world of the comics,
like Odin's spear, Gungnir, and Heimdall's
magic sword, Hofund.
Plus, there's Gram, the sword of the dragon-slayer
Sigmund, and Laevateinn, Loki's sword whose
name has the amazing translation of "Damage
Twig."
Others, however, are unique to the comics.
Before he proved himself worthy of Mjolnir,
Thor used a fearsome ax named Jarnbjorn, or
"Iron Bear."
"Is that a Dragonfang?"
"It is."
"My god.
It's the famed sword of the Valkyrie.”
Dragonfang, which appeared on the screen in
Thor: Ragnarok, is the sword carried by Brunhilde
the Valkyrie, so named because it was literally
carved from a dragon's tooth.
Before he got his hands on a couple of assault
rifles, Skurge the Executioner was fond of
using the Bloodaxe to behead his enemies,
and its violent name is pretty self-explanatory.
There are other hammers, too.
Loki once crafted a Mjolnir-like bludgeon
named Stormcaster that he gave to the X-Men's
resident weather-controlling goddess, Storm.
Eric Masterson briefly took on the identity
of Thor while the actual god was banished,
and when the Odinson returned, Eric became
a hero named Thunderstrike, wielding a magical
mace of the same name.
Most recently, Jane Foster took up a mystical
Asgardian artifact named Undrjarn the All-Weapon,
which can transform into any weapon that Jane
required in her new job as a Valkyrie.
Oh, and the Asgardian name?
Fittingly enough, for a weapon unique to the
comics page, it translates loosely to "Marvelous
Weapon."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.